there's a new wave of bands happening by Facebook,
but many of them are happening, not on Facebook
itself, but on Instagram, which is of course
owned by Facebook.
Uh, Facebook has publicly announced that they
are ready to do more to deal with hate speech
on their platform, and they say that they're
banning a whole bunch of different extremists.
This includes a Louis Farrakhan who is the
leader of the nation of Islam.
A truly, I mean, just vile, disgusting, anti
Semitic voice.
This is going to affect Alex Jones on Instagram.
Uh, you probably recall that Alex Jones was
already banned by faith from Facebook in and
of itself.
This is now from Instagram.
This is going to impact Milo Yiannopoulos,
the right wing person.
I don't know what, uh, uh, term to apply to
him.
Someone named Laura Loomer is being banned.
I don't even know who she is, but my instinct
is that my life is probably better not knowing
who she is.
She's gone.
Uh, and Facebook also announced that they
are banning white nationalism and white supremacy
from their platform.
So as usual, all of the normal talking points
are being trotted out.
This is censorship.
We'll hold on.
This is a private company establishing terms
of service and banning certain content.
Uh, then some will say, well, but the content
they're banning is a proxy towards right wing
thought.
What they're really banding is right wingers,
well, most right wingers don't see Louis Farrakhan
as right wing, although I certainly see him
personally as a reactionary.
So that's sort of a counterpoint.
But it's true.
I mean, white supremacy is mostly right wing,
uh, but this is the same as banning people,
uh, uh, for, uh, other ideologies that are
not protected.
This is not saying people who are members
of a certain religion aren't allowed on our
platform or, uh, people who are a certain
gender or nationality aren't allowed.
This is a ban on certain types of content
regardless of the identity of the person posting
it.
It is not banning people for their membership
in protected classes.
So anybody making this false analogy that
this is the same as a, uh, or worse than a
cake baker refusing to bake a gay wedding
cake.
For example.
We're talking about two very, very different
things here.
And, um, uh, by the way, I am going to be
debating this with Tim Pool tomorrow on the
Youtube Channel.
Okay.
Tuesday, May 7th at 6:00 PM Eastern.
I will be debating this very topic with independent
journalists, Tim Pool.
Um, I think the plan, we have to do a technical
test later today, but I think the idea is
to live stream it on both of our channels,
on our youtube channel and on his youtube
channel, which in total I think we're talking
about like 1.5 million subscribers across
both channels.
So I hope that you'll watch that and we will
really try to hash out, I mean, we're calling
it a debate.
I'm hoping that we will actually have a conversation
where we can figure out exactly where do we
agree, where do we disagree and what are some
reasonable steps forward, uh, to make sure
that there is no unnecessary limitations on
speech.
But that actual hate speech and how we define
that the devil is sort of in the details that
actual hate speech can be restricted by private
corporations as is there a right as protected
by the statutes that govern how businesses
operate in the United States.
So please check that out.
I think it's going to be a really great conversation
regardless of your thoughts about Tim Pool.
Uh, and some people in the audience liked
him.
Some people don't.
Uh, tomorrow, Tuesday, 6:00 PM eastern time